if you want to live a happy life and
live longer you have to pay attention to
this 85-year Harvard study that just
finished
so in 1938 researchers at Harvard set
out to find the answer to one simple
question what makes us happy in life
they then track
724 participants from all over the world
and every two years checked in within to
ask them how happy they were and what
was leading to their happiness
so the number one thing that they found
that led to happiness across all these
people was what they call Social Fitness
what that means is you want different
people in your life who check off these
boxes to help you stay happy the boxes
are Safety and Security learning and
growth emotional closeness and confiding
identity affirmation and shared
experiences romantic intimacy help both
practical and physical and fun and
relaxation
so if you want to be happy and you want
to live longer improve your Social
Fitness belief